This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. I'm going to tell you a story first about how a building got designed, a very unusual building in New York. The City Corp Tower. When it was built in 1977, City Corp Center was, at 59 stories, the seventh tallest building in the world. You know, I can still remember the first time I saw the City Corp Center. As you exit the local six subway station at Lexington and 53rd in Midtown Man, Hatton-Yor confronted by a sheer 915 foot building face, shooting up right from your feet. That's reporter Joel Werner.
这里是“99%隐形”播客。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我首先要给大家讲一个关于一座建筑是如何设计的故事，这是纽约一座非常不同寻常的建筑——花旗集团中心。建于1977年的花旗集团中心高59层，曾是世界上第七高的大楼。你知道，我至今仍能清晰地记得我第一次看到花旗集团中心的情景。当你从曼哈顿中城列克星敦大道和第53街交汇处的6号地铁站出站时，一栋高达915英尺的巨大建筑立面便赫然耸立在你的眼前，从你的脚下直冲云霄。这是记者乔尔·沃纳。
With its gleaming facade, glass and steel and striking 45 degree angle crown the CityCork Centre is truly one of the most spectacular skyscrapers on a skyline known for its spectacular skyscrapers but really it's the base of the building that takes your breath away this massive 59 story skyscraper levitates mid air, hovering 115 feet above the street corner. At first glance, the building seems to violate the basic laws of physics. When you look up, you look directly at the underside
凭借其闪闪发光的玻璃和钢结构立面，以及引人注目的45度角斜切屋顶，花旗集团中心绝对是一座天际线上最壮观的摩天大楼之一，而这片天际线本来就以壮观的摩天大楼闻名。但真正让人屏息凝神的其实是建筑的底部——这座庞大的59层摩天大楼仿佛悬浮在半空中，悬空盘旋在街角上方115英尺的高空。乍一看，这座建筑似乎违反了基本的物理定律。当你抬头仰望时，你看到的是
of the building corner, it overhangs the sidewalk. I mean, we'd expect a collar more even the grounds. Instead there's nothing. Just in there. Of course the building isn't really levitating. It's propped up on stills, which join the building at the midpoint of each side. It does not look starting. But it's got to be starting. It's got to be safe and they wouldn't have built it this way. Right? Yeah well that's a secret about this building. And it was literally a secret for nearly two decades after it was built.
建筑拐角的正下方，它悬挑在人行道上方。我的意思是，我们通常会期待看到更宽大或甚至直触地面的支撑。然而这里却什么都没有，只有空荡荡的空气。当然，这座建筑并不是真的在悬浮。它是由高柱支撑的，这些支柱与建筑每一侧的中点相连。这看起来很不寻常。但它肯定是非同寻常的，它必须是安全的，否则人们绝不会这样建造它，对吧？是的，这就是关于这座建筑的一个秘密。而且在它建成后的近二十年里，这甚至是一个彻头彻尾的秘密。
The City Corp Center could very well have blown over in the wind. What I wanted to know was when was this building going to fall down? The architect of the City Group Center was Hugh Stubbins, but most of the credit for this building is given to the chief structural engineer William Lamezir. You're laughing me, but I did conceive it on a napkin at a Greek restaurant in Cambridge. Lamezir passed away in 2007. This is him giving a talk at MIT in 1995.
花旗集团中心很有可能会在大风中被吹倒。我想知道的是，这座建筑到底什么时候会坍塌？花旗集团中心的建筑师是休·斯塔宾斯，但这座建筑的大部分荣誉都归功于首席结构工程师威廉·勒梅苏尔。你在笑我，但我确实是在剑桥的一家希腊餐馆的餐巾纸上构思出它的。勒梅苏尔于2007年逝世。这是他1995年在麻省理工学院做的一次演讲。
The whole problem was to build a building on a site that has a church in one corner. St. Peter's Lutheran Church. A chummy old building. It was the lowest point of Victorian architecture. I don't think it was that bad. St. Peter's sat at the corner of the lot. And when the church sold their land to CityCorp, it was on the condition that they build a new church in the exact same location. Beyond that, the company was free to build their skyscraper around the church and in the airspace above it. So, a plan was hatched to float the building over the church, hence the stilts. And because the church was in the corner of the lot,
整个问题的核心在于，要在场地的一个角落里有一座教堂的土地上建造一座建筑。那就是圣彼得路德教堂。一座舒适古朴的老建筑。它是维多利亚时代建筑中水平较低的作品。不过我觉得它其实没那么糟。圣彼得教堂位于地块的拐角处。当教堂把土地卖给花旗集团时，有一个条件，即他们必须在完全相同的位置重建一座教堂。除此之外，该公司可以围绕着这座教堂以及它上方的空域自由建造他们的摩天大楼。于是，一个让建筑悬浮在教堂上方的计划出炉了，这就是支柱的由来。因为教堂位于地块的角落，
LeMesh put the stilts in a kind of a weird place. You couldn't have columns in the corners where they ought to be in a conventional building, so they were removed to the middle. Placing the columns at the midpoint of each side, rather than in the corners, made the building less stable. So, for additional support, LeMesh had designed a chevron-bracing structure. Essentially, rows and rows of Vs each 8 stories high, pointing down the middle of each building face, to where the supporting columns had been moved. Actually, the architect wanted to keep the building simple,
勒梅苏尔把支柱放在了一个有点奇怪的位置。你无法在传统建筑本该有支柱的角落里设置立柱，所以它们被移到了中间。将柱子放置在每一侧的中点而不是角落里，使得建筑的稳定性降低了。因此，为了获得额外的支撑，勒梅苏尔设计了一种人字形支撑结构。本质上，这是一排排高达8层的“V”字形结构，一直延伸到每栋建筑立面的中部——也就是支撑柱被移去的地方。事实上，建筑师本来希望保持建筑的简洁，
that it's skinned because there was so much drama going on at the bottom and at the top. Anyway, he said, no, if you're going to have any diagonals, I don't ever want to see them. So the Chevron Brazing Structure was slipped under the skin of the building. It formed the CityCorp Center's skeleton. Now, one of the amazing things about this Chevron Bracing structure is that it's so lightweight that when the wind blows, it is more dynamically excitable than a building that weighed twice as much. In other words, it moves with the wind, which most people find really unsettling. Understandably, right? So, LeMeshert added something called a tuned mass damper.
也就是它的外立面，因为底部和顶部的戏剧性变化已经够多了。不管怎样，他说，不，如果你非得有任何斜线，我绝对不想看到它们。因此，人字形支撑结构被隐藏在建筑的外皮之下。它构成了花旗集团中心的骨架。现在，关于这个人字形支撑结构，最神奇的事情之一就是它非常轻巧，以至于当风吹过时，它的动态兴奋度比重量两倍于它的建筑还要高。换句话说，它会随风摆动，这让大多数人感到非常不安。这是可以理解的，对吧？所以，勒梅苏尔添加了一种叫做“调谐质量阻尼器”的东西。
The tuned mass damper is a massive concrete, which is 29 feet square and about 8 feet thick and weighs 400 tons. It is floated on pressurized oil bearings. The device sits at the very top of the building and acts to steady the oscillations. It offsets the wind gusts. So to recap, we have a 59-story tower floating on 115-foot stilts. Stilts which are not in the corner where you'd expect them, but rather in the middle of each side of the base with a skeleton of beams shaped like V's which make it super light
调谐质量阻尼器是一个巨大的混凝土块，有29见方英尺，厚约8英尺，重达400吨。它漂浮在加压油轴承上。这个装置位于建筑的最顶部，起到稳定振动的作用。它能抵消阵风的影响。所以概括一下，我们有一座高59层、悬浮在115英尺高空支柱上的塔楼。这些支柱不在你通常期望的角落里，而是在基座每一侧的中间，并配有一个由“V”形梁组成的骨架，这使得它对于摩天大楼来说
for a skyscraper. And to stop it from swaying in the wind, there's a 400 ton block of concrete on the roof, totally ingenious, really cutting edge design. And LeMesh's a pro, so in accordance with the New York City Building Code, he runs all kinds of mathematical models to make sure the building is going to hold up. And everything seemed just fine until, as LeMedre tells it, he got a phone call. June, 1978. I'm in my office.
极其轻盈。为了防止它在风中摇晃，屋顶上放着一个400吨重的混凝土块，这绝对是天才般的、真正尖端的设计。勒梅苏尔是一位专家，因此根据纽约市建筑规范，他运行了各种数学模型，以确保这座建筑能够支撑得住。一切似乎都很好，直到正如勒梅苏尔所说的那样，他接到了一个电话。1978年6月。我在办公室里。
I got a call from a student. I do not know the school. I wish he would call me from the past he never has, but anyway, as a real student from New Jersey, I think he was an architectural student, and his teacher had given him this building to study and report on because it's unusual. As LaMesa tells it, this precocious college senior calls him up to ask how his building structure is going to cope
我接到一个学生的电话。我不记得是哪所学校了。我真希望他能从过去给我打个电话，不过他从来没有。总之，那是新泽西来的一名真实的大学生，我想他是一名建筑系学生，他的老师把这座建筑交给他来研究并写报告，因为这座建筑很不寻常。正如勒梅苏尔所说，这个早熟的大学高年级学生打电话来询问他的建筑结构将如何应对
with quartering winds. An undergraduate student calling out the head of a world-renowned engineering firm on one of the most innovative skyscraper designs of it today. Cordering wins, the wins that caught the students' attention, are those that hit the building on the corner, exerting pressure on two faces at once. Lamexious calculations on the perpendicular wins, wins that hit the face of the building square on, seem to be fine.
斜向风。一个本科生竟然就当今最具创新性的摩天大楼设计之一，公开质询一家世界知名工程公司的负责人。斜向风，也就是引起这位学生注意的风，是指那些从建筑拐角处吹来、同时对两个立面施加压力的风。勒梅苏尔此前对垂直风（即正面直接吹向建筑立面的风）的计算似乎没有问题。
But as the story goes, the student raised the alarm about CityCorp Centre being particularly vulnerable at its corners. It turns out the measure had never run the numbers on what cornering winds would do to the building because normally buildings are strongest at their corners. But this is no normal building. Remember what's going on here? Supporting columns shifted to the midpoint of each building face, the chevron bracing skeleton, and the unusually light mass of the building.
但据这个故事所说，这位学生拉响了警报，指出花旗集团中心在拐角处特别脆弱。原来，勒梅苏尔此前从未计算过斜向风会对这座建筑造成什么影响，因为通常情况下，建筑物的拐角处是最坚固的。但这可不是一栋普通的建筑。还记得这里是怎么回事吗？支撑柱被移到了每个建筑立面的中点，还有人字形支撑的骨架，以及建筑异常轻盈的质量。
Taken alone, no one of these design quirks should have presented a problem. But as the student told LaMesa taken together, they left Citicorp Centre particularly vulnerable to a wind striking the structure at its corners. And when Lemezure started to investigate the student's claims, he realized that the root of the problem had to do with a change that had been made to the original plans. It had to do with how the Chevron Bracene structure was fastened together. Lemezure's plan originally called for the joints to be welded.
单看其中任何一个设计怪癖，都不应该构成问题。但正如这位学生对勒梅苏尔所说的那样，当这些因素结合在一起时，它们使得花旗集团中心在面对从建筑拐角处袭来的风时变得格外脆弱。当勒梅苏尔开始调查这位学生的说法时，他意识到问题的根源与对最初计划所做的一项更改有关。这与人字形支撑结构是如何固定在一起的有关。勒梅苏尔的计划原本要求这些接头采用焊接方式。
With full penetration welds, but the contractor had suggested using bolts instead. Bethlehem Steel actually designed beautiful bolted connections for the forces that my people gave them. It was a cost-saving measure. Lamejra says that this change would have happened without his knowledge. Given the wind load calculations Lamejra's team had supplied, welding these v's together was overkill. Run the math, and it looked like bolts would do just fine.
采用全熔透焊接，但承包商建议改用螺栓连接。伯利恒钢铁公司实际上针对我的人提供给他们的受力情况，设计了非常精美的螺栓连接。这是一个节省成本的措施。勒梅苏尔说，这一改动是在他不知情的情况下发生的。鉴于勒梅苏尔团队此前提供的风荷载计算结果，将这些“V”形结构焊接在一起其实是大材小用。经过数学计算，螺栓连接看起来完全可以胜任。
And bolts would have done just fine, I'm pretty much any other building, except City Corp Center had an Achilles heel on each of its four corners. Lameja could now see what no one else had. No one except for that Pesky student from New Jersey. And as Lameja started looking into the students' claims about these quartering wins, he realized the situation wasn't just bad. It was a disaster waiting to happen. The return period to failure was 16 years.
在几乎任何其他建筑上，螺栓连接都会表现得非常完美，唯独花旗集团中心的四个拐角各有一个阿喀琉斯之踵。勒梅苏尔现在看到了其他人看不到的东西。没有人看到，除了那个来自新泽西的讨厌的学生。当勒梅苏尔开始深入调查这位学生关于斜向风的说法时，他意识到情况不仅仅是糟糕。这是一场迟早会发生的灾难。倒塌的重现期为16年。
Think about that. Here's what that means. Lameja calculated the quartering win velocities required to topple the city corp center. He then matched these velocities to weather patterns to see how frequently, on average, winds strong enough to blow the building over, occurred. Lameja found that a storm strong enough to knock over the building hits New York City on average, once every 55 years. But that's only if the Tune Mass damper is working.
想想看。这意味着什么。勒梅苏尔计算了导致花旗集团中心倒塌所需的斜向风风速。然后，他将这些风速与天气模式进行对比，以了解平均而言，足以将建筑吹倒的强风发生的频率有多高。勒梅苏尔发现，一场足以吹倒该建筑的风暴平均每55年就会袭击一次纽约市。但这前提是调谐质量阻尼器正在正常运作。
The Tune Mass damper needs power to run, and if you're getting a huge storm, the measure realized it's not unlikely that the city could suffer a blackout. The measure ran the numbers again, this time imagining the damper without power. Without the damper, a storm strong enough to topple City Corp Center hits New York on average once every 16 years. To put this another way, for each year the building was standing there was about a one-in-sixteen chance of a storm potent enough to take out the City Corp Center. This building is 915 feet high.
调谐质量阻尼器需要电力才能运行，如果你遭遇了一场特大风暴，勒梅苏尔意识到这座城市极有可能会遭遇大面积断电。勒梅苏尔重新计算了数据，这一次他假设阻尼器在没有电力的情况下运行。如果没有阻尼器，一场足以吹倒花旗集团中心的风暴平均每16年就会袭击纽约一次。换句话说，在这座建筑矗立的每一年里，都有大约十六分之一的概率会发生一场足以摧毁花旗集团中心的强风暴。这座建筑高达915英尺。
If it failed, it would topple sideways in the wind, crashing into other Manhattan skyscrapers. A whole slew of buildings from mid-downto central park would fall like dominoes. What is this thing in real trouble? This brand-new skyscraper was on the verge of catastrophic failure. But the imminent disaster wasn't the result of one glaring oversight. Rather, it was a sequence of minor issues. Let's remember how we got here.
如果它倒塌了，它会在风中向侧面倒下，撞向曼哈顿的其他摩天大楼。从市中心到中央公园的一大串建筑都会像多米诺骨牌一样倒塌。这东西真的是陷入大麻烦了吗？这座崭新的摩天大楼正处于灾难性倒塌的边缘。但这场迫在眉睫的灾难并不是由某一个明显的疏忽造成的。相反，它是一系列微小问题叠加的结果。让我们回想一下我们是怎么走到这一步的。
This building was on stilts because they had to build over the church. And stilts placed at the corners would have been just fine, except the church was at the corner of the lot, so the stilts had to be in the middle of each face. And that could have been a-okay, except the offset stilts led Le Mégis to use an ultra-light chevron-bracing structure, which would have been perfectly adequate, except in the end, those chevron-vies were bolted, not welded together. And even that could have been fine, except no one thought about how vulnerable this crazy
这座建筑之所以立在支柱上，是因为他们必须在教堂上方建造。如果支柱放在拐角处本来会很好，但教堂位于地块的拐角处，所以支柱不得不放在每个立面的中间。这本来也完全没问题，但偏置的支柱导致勒梅苏尔使用了超轻的人字形支撑结构，这本来也完全足够了，直到最后，那些人字形“V”架是用螺栓连接而不是焊接在一起的。甚至连这一点也本可以没问题，直到没有人去思考这个疯狂的设计在面对
design was to wind blowing at its corners. No one except an anonymous college student. The measure went to CityCorp Chairman Walter Riston and told him they would need to open up the building and weld it back together. And how much is going to cost? I don't think it's going to cost an awful lot. Million or two? That's nothing. We're building
吹向其拐角的风时是多么脆弱。没有人，除了一个匿名的大学生。勒梅苏尔去找花旗集团董事长沃尔特·里斯顿，告诉他他们需要打开建筑并重新将其焊接起来。这要花多少钱？我想这不会花太多钱。一两百万？那不算什么。我们在建造它时
the cost of $155 million and if it falls down. From here, the Measure and E's team worked with the city called Big Wigs to coordinate emergency repairs on the building. With the help of the NYPD, they worked out an evacuation plan spanning a 10 block radius. They had 2,500 red cross volunteers on standby and three different weather services employed 24-7 to keep an eye on potential wind storms. They welded through the night and quid at daybreak just as the building occupants returned to work.
花费了1.55亿美元，如果它倒塌了的话。从这里开始，勒梅苏尔和他的团队与城市大人物们合作，协调建筑的紧急维修工作。在纽约警察局的帮助下，他们制定了一个横跨10个街区半径的疏散计划。他们有2500名红十字会志愿者处于待命状态，并雇用了三个不同的天气服务机构进行全天候监控，以密切关注潜在的风暴。他们彻夜焊接，直到天亮、建筑内的上班族返回工作岗位时才收工。
But all this happened in secret over three months without telling anyone who worked there. Which is the part of the story I kinda have a problem with. I mean, isn't this situation serious enough to warrant informing the building's tenants? My wife works in a skyscraper in Midtown Manhattan and you know, it's about informed consent. I'd want her to be able to make the judgement called about whether or not to go work in a faulty building. Not to haven't made for her.
但这一切都在三个月内秘密进行，没有告诉任何在那里工作的人。这也是我对此故事有点看法的一部分。我的意思是，这种情况难道不够严重到需要通知大楼的租户吗？我妻子在曼哈顿中城的一座摩天大楼里工作，你知道的，这关乎知情同意。我希望她能够自己判断是否要去一栋有缺陷的大楼里上班，而不是由别人替她做出决定。
Their thinking was, a contingency plan was in place and ready to be invoked as soon as a storm strong enough to blow the building down was in striking distance of New York. Except… There was a giant storm racing up the east coast. Hurricane Ella. Lameja says the powers that be were just hours away from calling in the evacuation. But the hurricane veered into the Atlantic before it hit New York, and in the end, the public was never notified. And I know what you're thinking. If only there was some kind of independent organization that serves the public's right
他们的想法是，应急计划已经就位，一旦有足以将建筑吹风倒塌的强风逼近纽约，就可以立即启动。但是……一场巨大的风暴正沿东海岸狂飙突进——“艾拉”飓风。勒梅苏尔说，当权者距离下达疏散令仅差几个小时。但在它袭击纽约之前，飓风转向吹入了远洋，最终公众从未得到通知。我知道你在想什么。要是能有某种独立的机构来维护公众的知情权就好了，
to know that might wonder why. City Corp Center was a glow with blow torches all night every night, you know, something like a newspaper. Except the New York Times was on strike. Not only did the New York Times go on strike, but all the newspapers in the war went on strike until October. So we had a pressed blackout and that was the greatest thing that ever happened. So word never got out and construction was finished.
可能会有人好奇，为什么花旗集团中心整晚整晚地闪烁着焊枪的火花，你知道的，比如某种报纸。除了《纽约时报》当时正在罢工。《纽约时报》不仅在罢工，而且战争中的所有报纸都在罢工，一直持续到十月。所以我们遭遇了新闻灯光管制，而这成了有史以来发生过的最好的事情。因此消息从未走漏，施工最终完成了。
And City Corp Center has remained standing ever since. Long enough to be renamed City Group Center and later, 601 Lexington. And this whole thing remained a secret for almost 20 years. In the early 90s, writer Joe Morgan Stern overheard the story being told at a party. He interviewed LaMesa and broke the story in the New Yorker in 1995. LaMesa went on to tell the story publicly, like he did at MIT, which is how we have him talking about this. And after the story got out, it was written up as a textbook case of good ethics in structural
自那以后，花旗集团中心一直矗立在那里。时间久到它被更名为花旗集团中心，后来又被称为莱克星顿大道601号。整个事件被当作一个秘密保守了近20年。90年代初，作家乔·摩根斯特恩在一次聚会上无意中听到了这个故事。他采访了勒梅苏尔，并于1995年在《纽约客》杂志上独家报道了这个故事。勒梅苏尔随后开始公开讲述这个故事，就像他在麻省理工学院所做的那样，这就是我们为什么能听到他谈论此事的原因。故事曝光后，它被当作结构工程中良好职业道德的教科书式案例写入了教材。
engineering. New York was spared a tremendous loss of life and the annihilation of its skyline, all because Bill Lamege was humble enough to give time to the inquiry of an undergraduate student. Thank goodness for this uppity-colored senior and his thesis and kudos to Bill Lamege who, through his humility and heroism, saves the day. And that's really the end of this story. Accept. Now wait a minute, there are a couple more things here.
纽约免于了一场巨大的生命损失和天际线的毁灭，这一切都只是因为比尔·勒梅苏尔足够谦逊，愿意花时间倾听一名本科生的质询。感谢这位自命不凡的大学高年级学生和她的毕业论文，也向比尔·勒梅苏尔致敬，他通过自己的谦逊和英雄主义拯救了危局。这确实是这个故事的结局。不过等等。现在等等，这里还有好几件事情。
Let's take a step back and remember how this story starts. I got a call from a student. He was a real student from the Jersey. It was an architectural student. This teacher had given him this building to study. I do not know the school. I wish he would call me. The way LaMesha tells it and had Joe Morgan Stern told it in the New Yorker,
让我们退一步，回想一下这个故事是如何开始的。我接到一个学生的电话。那是一个来自新泽西的真正的学生。他是一名建筑系学生。他的老师把这座建筑交给他研究。我不记得是哪所学校了。我真希望他能给我打电话。正如勒梅苏尔所讲的那样，以及乔·摩根斯特恩在《纽约客》中所报道的那样，
the college student, the young hero of our our story was lost to history. Okay, wait for it. Wait for this moment. It's a good one. Here it comes. It would have been some time in the early 90s. I remember being upstairs in my bedroom and had one of my sons. He was sort of hanging off me as I was trying to put him down to go to bed. And suddenly my husband who had been downstairs started yelling a little bit and saying, Diane, Diane, quick, quick turn on the TV. Your thesis building is on TV. This is Diane Hottley. As far as we can tell, she was the student in the measure story. And so I, you know, holding the baby with one arm, I fumbled for the remote and got to the channel
那个大学生、我们故事中的年轻英雄在历史中被遗忘了。好了，等等看。等待这一刻。这是一个好时刻。它来了。那应该是在90年代初期的某个时候。我记得当时我在楼上的卧室里，我的一个儿子正挂在我身上，当时我正试图把他放下床去睡觉。突然，一直在楼下的丈夫开始大喊大叫起来，说：“黛安，黛安，快，快打开电视。你的毕业论文建筑上电视了。”这是黛安·霍特利。据我们所知，她就是勒梅苏尔故事中的那个学生。所以，我一边用一只手臂抱着婴儿，一边摸索着遥控器，调到了那个频道，
just in time to hear... This building could have killed tens of thousands of people. The extraordinary chain of events began with a phone call out of the blutes from a student in New Jersey whose professor had told him to write a paper on the city called Tower. William Lamejert. And I explained to the student in the telephone call that he could tell his professor. I was a guest. I nearly dropped my baby. This was the first time Diane had ever heard of the emergency retrofits around the clock
刚好赶上听到……这座建筑本可能杀死数万人。这起非同寻常的事件链始于一个突如其来的电话，打来电话的是新泽西的一名学生，其教授曾让他写一篇关于花旗集团大厦的论文。威廉·勒梅苏尔。我在电话里向这位学生解释说，她可以告诉她的教授。我当时大吃一惊。我差一点把婴儿掉在地上。这是黛安第一次听说围绕大楼展开的24小时紧急加固、
weather monitoring the evacuation plans in the involvement of a student. So, when she heard LaMesa reference a student, a male student, I, of course, assumed, you know, gosh, there was some guide studying the building as well. And wow, you know, how could I miss this? Wow. So, it was pretty remarkable, but I, of course, assumed at the time that there was another fellow who had been a better researcher than I had been. In fact, Diane never even considered that she might be the student in the story. That is, until she went to a Princeton event honoring her thesis advisor David Billington.
天气监测、疏散计划以及有学生参与的事项。所以，当她听到勒梅苏尔提到一个学生、一个男学生时，我当然以为，天哪，肯定还有某个男生也在研究这座建筑。天哪，我怎么会错过这个？哇。所以，这相当引人注目，但我当时当然以为，肯定还有另一个家伙，他比我做了更好的研究。事实上，黛安从没想过自己可能是故事中的那个学生。直到她去参加普林斯顿大学的一场活动，以表彰她的论文导师大卫·比林顿。
When I showed up at the event, David said, well, have you ever heard of the problems with the City Corp Center? And I said, yes, have you ever heard of the problems with the City Corp Center? And I said, yes, isn't that pretty remarkable? I wonder who it was that discovered this problem. And he said, you know, Diane, there are very few engineering schools in New Jersey. And quite frankly, I know all of them. And I know the heads of the programs of all of them and I've talked to all of them There was no other student from New Jersey that was studying the building except for you
当我出现在活动现场时，大卫说：“嗯，你听说过花旗集团中心的问题吗？”我说：“听说过，你听说过花旗集团中心的问题吗？”我说：“听说过，这难道不是很了不起吗？我不知道究竟是谁发现了这个问题。”他说：“你知道吗，黛安，新泽西的工程学院非常少。坦白说，我知道其中所有的学校。我也知道他们所有项目负责人的名字，我都跟他们聊过。除了你之外，没有其他新泽西的学生在研究这座建筑。”
So it must have been you. Yes, it's I don't know about any other student This is David Billington the thesis advisor. Yes, my name is David Billington That's correct and I'm an engineer thesis advisor. Yes, my name is David Billington, that's correct, and I'm an engineer, spent 53 years at Princeton as a faculty member. I was Diane Hartley's thesis advisor. She wrote the most outstanding thesis of anybody who was a very low of your seeing it. Two big volumes, yes, anyway.
“所以一定是你。”是的，是我。我不知道有没有其他学生。这是论文导师大卫·比林顿。是的，我叫大卫·比林顿，没错，我是一名工程师。在普林斯顿大学担任教职员长达53年。我是黛安·霍特利的论文导师。她写出了所有人中最为出色的毕业论文，这是一篇非常了不起的作品。两大卷，是的，总之。
To hear Diane Hartley and David Billington tell the story, Diane wasn't some in your face nodal. Here's her version of the events. So I was 21 years old and I was a senior at Princeton University where I was studying architecture and urban planning. My thesis, I had selected the topic of the City Corp Center in New York, which had only recently been completed and occupied. She reached out to Lamejus firm to get the calculations that they had run, and then she tried
听黛安·霍特利和大卫·比林顿讲述这个故事，黛安并不是那种锋芒毕露的人。这是她对事件的描述：当时我21岁，是普林斯顿大学的大四学生，主修建筑学和城市规划。我的毕业论文，我选择了纽约的花旗集团中心作为主题，该建筑当时才刚刚建成并投入使用。她联系了勒梅苏尔的公司，获取了他们运行的计算数据，然后她尝试
to replicate the math herself. To do the work again from the start and see if she got the same answers as Lamejus engineers. David Billington, her advisor, asked her to ask Lamejus firm about the quartering winds. The quartering wind, I thought that was a problem and that it should be looked at. So I obtained calculations from the design engineer from Lamejus office and I concluded the governing loading condition was the wind hitting the corner of the building. But the math just wasn't coming out right.
自己重新推演这些数学计算。从头开始重新做这项工作，看看她是否能得到和勒梅苏尔的工程师们一样的答案。她的导师大卫·比林顿要求她向勒梅苏尔的公司询问关于斜向风的事。斜向风，我认为这是一个问题，应该对其进行研究。所以我从设计工程师、勒梅苏尔的办公室获得了计算结果，我得出的结论是，主控荷载工况是风吹向建筑的拐角。但数学计算结果就是对不上。
I was struggling with the calculations. I assumed, of course, that the engineer had done the right thing and any inconsistency that I might find would be my error. The building was standing. After all, she was just a college senior and LaMessia and his people were established, internationally renowned, professional, structural engineers. Diane got back in touch with LaMessia's firm, although she never talked with LaMessia herself. I never called LaMessia, I never said these things that were documented in the various reports that had been published today.
我在计算上苦苦挣扎。当然，我假设工程师做了正确的事情，我可能发现的任何不一致之处都会是我自己的错误。毕竟建筑还好好地立在那里。她只是一名大学高年级学生，而勒梅苏尔和他的团队是成熟的、享誉国际的专业结构工程师。黛安重新联系了勒梅苏尔的公司，尽管她从未与勒梅苏尔本人交谈过。我从未给勒梅苏尔打过电话，我也从未说过今天已发表的各种报告中所记录的那些话。
Diane did talk to a junior engineer, LaMeshna's New York office, named Joel Weinstein. She showed him her calculations. But at the end of the day, no, I didn't feel that I had put my finger on a major problem. I assumed I was wrong and wasn't understanding things. Even David Bellinton, who had told Diane to look into the quartering winds in the first place, didn't think there was any imminent threat. I mean, I don't think either of us really were in a position to say at the time, you've got to do something Bill right away.
黛安确实与勒梅苏尔纽约办公室的一位初级工程师交谈过，他叫乔尔·温斯坦。她向他展示了她的计算结果。但归根结底，不，我不觉得自己发现了一个重大问题。我以为自己错了，没有搞懂这些事情。甚至连最初告诉黛安去调查斜向风的大卫·比林顿，也不认为存在任何迫在眉睫的威胁。我的意思是，我不认为我们当时有任何人处于能够说“比尔，你必须马上采取行动”的位置。
We didn't have that feeling. I had the feeling that she should talk to the designers and find out whether this quartering wind had been considered and if so what was the outcome. But somehow Diane's discovery got silently passed up the totem bowl within LeMessage's firm. We asked Joel Weinstein the engineer about meeting check with Bill. I would have been the logical thing to do and he probably did that. I never heard that. You never heard it, I guess. We asked Joel Weinstein the engineer about meeting Diane and what happened afterwards, but he says he has no memory of this either way. Though he does acknowledge that if Diane
我们没有那种感觉。我觉得她应该和设计人员谈谈，弄清楚是否考虑过这种斜向风，如果是的话，结果是什么。但不知何故，黛安的发现悄无声息地在勒梅苏尔公司内部的层级中被往上汇报了。我们问工程师乔尔·温斯坦关于和比尔核对的情况。这本该是合乎逻辑的事情，他可能也那样做了。我从未听说过这个。你从没听说过，我想是的。我们问工程师乔尔·温斯坦关于与黛安会面以及之后发生的事情，但他表示对此毫无记忆。尽管他确实承认，如果黛安
remembered speaking to him, then it probably happened. And that in such a circumstance, he would have passed her message on to LeMeshah. So it could be that's why LeMameja remembers speaking to a male student. He was conflating Diane Hartley, the student with Joel Weinstein, his own staffer. Now, of course, it is possible that there was a male student. A third man. Who somehow had the same data as Diane and actually did talk to Lameja on the phone. But I find it really hard to believe that such a person didn't come forward and claim
还记得和他交谈过，那么这件事很可能发生过。并且在那种情况下，他本应将她的信息传达给勒梅苏尔。所以这可能就是为什么勒梅苏尔记得曾和一个男学生交谈过。他把学生黛安·霍特利与他自己的员工乔尔·温斯坦搞混了。当然，也有可能确实存在一个男学生。第三个人。他不知何故拥有和黛安一样的数据，并且真的在电话里和勒梅苏尔交谈过。但我很难相信这样一个人在故事曝光后没有站出来聚光灯下。
the spotlight after the story broke. Gender aside, Diane definitely doesn't fit the image of the precocious student. She identified a problem without even recognizing the significance of what she had done for decades. It's not that I did something. It's that perhaps my questions helped someone figure something out. Perhaps my questions were meant to be. I think if I had really realized that there was a problem and put my finger on it and raised it up the flagpole, I could pat myself on the back for having done something that was pretty remarkable. But at the end of the day, I feel like I was a bit player in a play
抛开性别不谈，黛安绝对不符合那种早熟学生的形象。她在甚至没有认出自己所做事情的重大意义的情况下就识别出了一个问题，并且持续了几十年。并不是说我做了什么。而是也许我的问询帮助某人弄明白了某些事情。也许我的问询是命中注定的。我想，如果我当时真的意识到这是一个问题，并指出了它并把它向上汇报，我可能会为自己做了一件相当了不起的事而自我感觉良好。但归根结底，我觉得自己只是一个有着圆满结局的剧本中的一个小配角。
that had a happy ending. So yes, she deserves more credit than she's gotten. You can tell her that. I think that's right. That's the, I think, the code for this. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Joel Werner and Sam Greenspan, with Katie Mingle Avery Troubleman and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Michael Verdaro, who wrote the AI-A Trust White Paper about City Corp Center, Samille Raghavan at the National Academy of Engineering for help and has tracked down archival audio of William LaMesa and Alan Bello's of the website, Damn Interesting for talking to me about this about two years ago at this point.
所以是的，她应得的赞誉比她实际得到的要多。你可以告诉她这一点。我想这没错。我想这就是这期节目的密码。“99%隐形”本周由乔尔·沃纳和萨姆·格林斯潘制作，凯蒂·明格尔、艾弗里·特拉布曼和罗曼·马尔斯共同参与。特别感谢迈克尔·韦尔达罗，他撰写了关于花旗集团中心的 AIA 信任白皮书；感谢美国国家工程学院的萨米尔·拉加万提供的帮助，她追踪到了威廉·勒梅苏尔的档案音频；还要感谢网站“Damn Interesting”的艾伦·贝洛斯，大约两年前就这个话题与我进行了交流。
We are a Project 91.7 Local Public Radio KALW in San Francisco and produced out of the offices of ArcSign, beautiful architecture firm and beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can keep up with this show and all the people who make this show on Facebook, Twitter, and Tumblr. If you want to see some pictures of CityCorp Center, go to 99pi.org. All right, I make sure you say that. Wait, sorry, I said something. I say this is not architecture we're talking about.
我们是旧金山 91.7 独立公共广播电台 KALW 的节目，由位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的建筑事务所 ArcSign 的办公室制作出品。你可以在 Facebook、Twitter 和 Tumblr 上关注本节目以及所有参与制作的人员。如果你想看一些花旗集团中心的照片，请访问 99pi.org。好的，我得确保把话说清楚。等等，抱歉，我刚才说错话了。我说我们谈论的不是建筑。
This is structure, engineering structure. I'm very sensitive about that. I don't want to mix up these things. I think that in this case, the measures design was a brilliant structural design but it was all covered over typical of architects to cover it over so you could never see it. Most people make that decision about tall buildings that they wanted to be architecture and that's why most of them are so
这是结构，工程结构。我对这一点非常敏感。我不想把这些事情混为一谈。我认为在这个案例中，勒梅苏尔的设计是一个绝妙的结构设计，但它被完全遮盖起来了——这很符合建筑师的作风，把它遮盖起来让你永远看不见。大多数人在对待高层建筑时都会做出那样的决定，他们希望它是建筑艺术，这就是为什么大多数高楼都那么
bad. But anyway that's a prejudice. So it will be clear this is structure not architecture. But what we're talking clear this is structured not architecture. But what we're talking about is structure, not architecture. Radio to be. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
糟糕。但不管怎样，这是一种偏见。所以我们要明确，这是结构，而不是建筑。但我们要明确，这是结构，而不是建筑。但我们要谈论的是结构，而不是建筑。电台。来自 PRX。本集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。